foreign
[Applause]
TV special this is part three of
craziest combos in Tekken tournaments
wow oh nice
well oh going around well I have never
seen that wow what is going on
oh here it is
a demon let's go I probably worth seeing
it look at the light bulb oh my goodness
he probably had to slip away
[Music]
Christmas
[Applause]
it's back
maybe now
you've got to use a race ride
[Applause]
[Music]
could potentially kill this there you go
is this gonna kill
[Music]
him
what a laser well calculated
well calculated there for Vermillion
night
[Music]
Come On Son finish the Stream
look at this me slowly working his way
back once again Joey Fury the race on
the down four two
so beautiful
last minute oh
[Music]
secret thick Discord take
the arrival stream first time I've ever
seen it ever that was insane I watched a
lot of Korean DMS and I don't think I've
seen that I've never seen that wow
good job
[Music]
look at how much damage it did
I think I killed
I think I just killed that's like 70
percent
somebody call the police there's a
robbery happening he's dead he's [__]
dead
um
but not enough to matter right now one
guard has been rage after the next coach
it's gonna be over anyone's around here
we go oh he got the loss it needed with
rage big damage on the whole ride
[Applause]
game number one that will be Arsen pass
he's put him in a rage and immediately
lost him with the knee
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
playing
[Music]
oh
wow that point for Anderson move on this
man engine got up and sat there for
protected in this new town for two and
then
okay okay oh my God are we going
downstairs yes we are oh
no
oh my God
[Music]
wow
did we miss something make sure to leave
your comments below of any matches you
had in mind that can be considered for
the series
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
[Music]
foreign